One of the things that sets esports apart, is that it's truly global.
Still, pro players are more common in some places than others.
"I love my country. I'm coming from the country that made me what I am today."
"So I want to give something back."
(Casting)
Ladislav “GuardiaN” Kovács managed to make his way into the elite of Counter-Strike’s
competitive community from a small European country mostly unknown in the scene.
And he did it through his sheer dedication to the game.
(Casting)
But despite playing with some of the best players the game has ever seen, and holding
his own as one of the most versatile and effective AWPers ever,
(Casting)
There is still something GuardiaN has yet to do:
Win a major.
"There he is, the world's best sniper."
Born in 1991, GuardiaN grew up in Slovakia.
At age 10, his brother’s copy of Counter-Strike found its way into the home, and it was instantly
something that GuardiaN understood.
"In 2001, it was all 1.3."
"And the old estate map. When my brother brough CS home, I started playing the game 1v10"
"The hardest bots. And I felt like I could shoot I could do everything I want."
Over the next eight years, GuardiaN would continue to play 1.6, but also tried Counter-Strike: Source.
All the while, he was still living in Slovakia and playing with domestic teams there.
It was during this time that Guardian picked up the AWP.
And if it wasn’t for the fact that he was playing in a smaller region, he may not have become an AWPer at all.
"I began sniping just because our city didn't have a solid sniper that could actually help us."
"So that's the story behind it, and I'm happy it happened that way."
During this period his first roster that competed at an international LAN was Reason Gaming,
a combined Czech and Slovak roster.
His first CS:Source LAN event was Lan79, a recurring French tournament, where some thought
the team was cheating.
But GuardiaN, just under a year into his time with the game, was still playing like it was 1.6
"Ah you know coming from 1.6 you just want to play the game the same way like you want to wallbang
and stuff like this so."
GuardiaN made the jump to CS:GO after it became clear that the title would be embraced by
the competitive community: even if their initial reception was less than cordial.
"The other three like Luckey Ted, zid. All three of them weren't convinced that CS:GO was going to be big."
"And I don't think any... All three of those players didn't like the game."
He still didn’t love the game, and even considered switching away from the AWP, given
the changes to the weapon.
"I hated the game completely, I don't know why I didn't like it. Too much trash on the map, like chickens
and stuff so."
Despite eventually coming around to the game, GuardiaN spent his early career in GO playing
playing on mostly regional teams, including the Czech/Slovakian mix team MyDGB.
Now working a job at Hewlett-Packard, GuardiaN had to find time for the game, even bringing
his PC to work during a night shift so he could play a qualifier for the first IEM Katowice tournament.
"It was risky. We had a team of five people, like shift. And my guys were really nice and they knew
I'm playing CS competitively. The shift captain told me, yeah I'm allowed to, so they didn't tell anyone
that I've done it."
GuardiaN’s first big break outside his region would come with Virtus.Pro in June 2013.
At the time, VP was a Russian and Ukrainian mixed team and GuardiaN didn’t speak any Russian.
He was forced to learn as he went, and credits Fox with helping him.
A month after GuardiaN’s addition, ANGE1 and Dosia left for Astana Dragons.
GuardiaN was on the move again, but had made enough of an impact outside his home region to get noticed.
He was chosen as the 10th best player of 2013 by HLTV.org.
GuardiaN’s AWPing style was versatile, focused around his ability to flick with the AWP whether
he was holding an angle defensively, or peeking aggressively.
(Casting)
"Everytime I wanted to buy awp, I buy the awp even if I have no armour."
Another hallmark of his play is his uncanny ability to clutch even in terrible situations.
(Casting)
After playing on a mix team with Edward, who had also been part of Astana Dragons,
GuardiaN was invited to join Natus Vincere.
GuardiaN had spent a long time in his home region and had only a short-lived stint with VP.
But Na`Vi would end up being his home for years to come.
Also on the roster was Zeus, the team’s in-game leader renowned for his slow and methodical
approach to the game.
(Casting)
That strategy gave GuardiaN plenty of time to find picks while the team played
around him.
"He was very good at reading opponents. And he had the balls to call tactics even 50 seconds left."
The team’s Major debut was at ESL Major Series One: Katowice, but they finished
13th-16th after a full month of bootcamp.
But an immediate opportunity to rebound presented itself.
Fnatic had declined their spot to StarLadder Starseries IX based on the ongoing crisis
in Ukraine, but the tournament would be huge for the resurgence of the Na`Vi squad.
They didn’t drop a single map as the team defeated NiP twice, and Titan.
It was exactly the sort of win that the new roster needed.
Suddenly, they were on the map, and GuardiaN’s style broke into the mainstream.
"It feels always kind of special because it was my first bigger event."
"I think back then it was like 100k or 150k. So yeah, it feels special and still I feel the CIS fans and everything
like that, they stayed behind me and cheered for me so yeah."
In the run-up to the next 2014 Major in Cologne they looked like they could do real damage.
(Casting)
But after getting out of groups as the second seed, they ran directly into Fnatic.
That series featured furious action, but Na`Vi went out in a narrow 16-14 on Nuke.
"Fnatic go through after a hard fought battle, all three maps going to Nuke.
Although Na`Vi were firmly in the conversation as a contender, it was over three months until
they got another shot at a Valve Major.
"I don't know it was always a close matchup, even in Cologne we lost 2-1 to Fnatic, 16-14 last map."
"So we always missed something. I hope it will be better this time and we will show better results."
Na`Vi were eliminated in the semifinals by eventual winners LDLC.
(Casting)
The  next few months were quiet for the team in
terms of competition until the next Major in March 2015 at ESL One Katowice.
After again working their way out of groups, the team fell to the same french players as
they did in Cologne: this time, representing Team EnVyUs.
"I'm glad we got to see the Dust2 that came out of Na'Vi was inspirational. And GuardiaN, such a key figure."
GuardiaN was the only member of Na`Vi to be positive overall for the series, and the team
went out in the quarterfinals.
They had shown some positive potential but so far had only broken the Top 4 at a Major once.
Outside of Valve majors the team had only seen significant success only at the most recent
three StarLadder events and at DreamHack Summer.
After the tournament, starix stepped down from the team and became a coach, analyst
and a manager.
Flamie joined as a stand-in before becoming a permanent member.
While GuardiaN had often been relied upon to take a starring role, Flamie added firepower
to the team that gave him more room to work with.
Despite the team’s inconsistent results, GuardiaN was becoming a hallmark name, synonymous
with excellence with the AWP.
(Casting)
He, along with French AWPer KennyS, were the two names on the tip of everyone’s tongue
when asked about the game’s best snipers.
But the two had very different approaches to the game.
(Casting)
"Ahh but there is no doubt he's always been among the top three best awpers in the world."
"With like me"
The middle of 2015 again saw mixed results.
Na`Vi took ESL Pro League 1 and StarSeries XIII from both of France’s best rosters,
and won ESWC 2015, though some notable rosters
were not attending.
(Casting)
France had its revenge at ESL One Cologne, the next Valve major.
After the group stage, Na`Vi had to play against EnvyUs in the quarterfinals:
Kenny and GuardiaN facing off.
(Casting)
And though the maps were close, they lost 2-0.
It was another Top 8 appearance for Na`Vi where they had not met their own expectations.
Over the next few months they managed Top 4 appearances at a bevy of events but didn’t
win any.
Still, their consistency suggested DreamHack Open Cluj-Napoca 2015, the upcoming Valve
Major, might be their best chance yet to take it all.
(Casting)
Even in the early stages of this tournament, nV and Kenny were there to threaten Na`Vi.
In the same group, Na`Vi lost their match against the french side but still made it
out of the group as second-seed.
The path to the grand finals was not easy.
Luminosity Gaming, the best Brazilian team, were increasingly showing they were top-tier
competitors, and Ninjas in Pyjamas stood in the way in the semifinals.
But once they had fought all the way to grand finals, it was Team EnVyUs again standing in their way.
"And this is just a legendary lineup going against another legendary lineup, two legendary lineups going at it,
and two legendary AWPers going at it. And today we'll see one of those AWPers who's never won a Major
before, take the title."
Na`Vi’s dominance on their map pick of Train was immediately challenged by nV,
And the French side took it 16-14, including a heartbreaking 1v2 by Happy.
(Casting)
Na`Vi now had to somehow win on Cobble, a map they, for all intents and purposes, didn’t play
They couldn’t push it to a third map.
"And there it is, nV winning the last Major of 2015 and the second final in a row here for three of these players."
The first for Kenny and Apex."
A 16-5 stomp saw GuardiaN get the closest he had ever been to a championship and then
fall short.
"Of course it hurts to lose a final like that because next map was Cobble, and we never practiced Cobble before."
This was the major GuardiaN could have won.
"It just hurts, when you see how you lose the final."
"Of course if you're a professional player you're thinking about it, you have the memories from it so yeah."
As the numbers showed, he wasn’t the problem.
GuardiaN was +12 across both maps, better than any other player in the server besides
Kenny.
He was also selected as the tournament MVP.
(Casting)
As the dust settled from Cluj, the team had an incredible rebound performance at IEM San Jose
though the event was an invitational.
"I'm speechless like, this was the first time that we won like a team, we were playing as a team."
"I think we did a great job."
The team was now consistently making finals, and a major win seemed possible.
(Casting)
In just over two months in early 2016, the team raked in over $150,000 in prize money.
At Counter Pit League S2 Finals, GuardiaN destroyed the competition, posting unbelievable
stats in the grand final against Astralis.
So when MLG Major Championship Columbus rolled around, Na`Vi were again in the discussion
as one of the favorites.
But already, the odds were stacked against GuardiaN.
"I think injury was there like for a month. Before Counter-Pit I mean. And I never realised that it could be bad."
"Sometimes I had pain in the wrist but I always thought, exhaustion like I got exhausted in my arm or something."
I used to play a lot of CS back then."
The injury had been ongoing, but GuardiaN ignored the problem, thinking it
was just normal wear-and-tear.
Though the team managed to top their group and defeat NiP and Astralis without dropping
a map, the injury had flared up by the grand finals series against Luminosity.
GuardiaN, trying to compensate for his reduced range of movement in his wrist,
cranked up the mouse sensitivity settings.
But it wasn’t enough,
(Casting)
and GuardiaN had one of the worst performances of his career in an event final.
"Story of the tournament so far, you've got GuardiaN, he hasn't shown up
Someone needs to get on the phone and ask where he is."
The Major title again slipped away.
In the aftermath, despite some early concerns, a doctor did eventually clear him to play
at DreamHack Malmo, the next big event for the team.
"GuardiaN his wrist, his mouse hand, has been injured. He had an inflamed bone or something in his wrist."
"But apparently he's been cleared by the doctors to attend the event, but it is some strain on himself."
They took second.
The next Valve Major for Na`Vi was in Cologne and barely three months from the previous
one in Columbus.
But instead of another finals appearance, they went out 5th-8th with a shocking loss
to Team Liquid and their new talent, s1mple.
(Casting)
By August 2016 Na’Vi had decided to remove Zeus and add s1mple, but the change worsened
divisions in the team that had appeared earlier
in the year.
"I think like after we kicked Zeus, I think the change of lineup didn't happen the way it should happen."
Though s1mple was an incredible talent, there were questions about whether the change was what the team
needed.
While the space between the last two Majors had been short, it would be nearly a half a year before the next.
In the interim, both Na`Vi and GuardiaN managed a career milestone: winning a big premier
event with a $250,000 prize pool.
(Casting)
At ESL One New York, Na`Vi went undefeated in the Swiss group and then defeated Team
Liquid and Virtus.Pro in the bracket to take first.
GuardiaN, overcome by emotion, refused to hide it.
"I've been with you a long time, we've known each other for over a dozen years, I know how much this means to
you."
"Can you put it in words for your fans?"
"I can't. I'm just speechless. It feels so f***ing, so good."
"The thing is. Why I was super emotional was because, I've been dedicated to CS 24/7,
I chose CS over friends, I chose CS over family, over everything. And thinking about I lost so many finals,
and then finally winning one, it changed a lot. You think about it like, finally the dedication showed
I can win tournaments like that so."
Though it was a huge moment for GuardiaN and his team, it would be the last big win for the roster
before his departure.
The win hadn’t healed the cracks in the foundation of the team.
Na`Vi didn’t make Top 4 at either the ELEAGUE Major: Atlanta 2017 or the PGL Major Krakow.
Their only placement of note in the first half of 2017 was at the Adrenaline Cyber League, a CIS-region tournament
where they placed second among four teams.
"Jet lagged, tired, they still did it. I mean impressive performance from VP you got to give it to them."
"Congratulations to the guys."
After Krakow, both the team and GuardiaN were
faced with hard decisions about the future
of the roster.
Na`Vi had been a home for GuardiaN for three and a half years.
And during that time he had clearly shown his skill as one of the world’s best AWPers,
(Casting)
But it was also clear that there were other opportunities elsewhere, and the internal
divisions in the team weren’t going to disappear.
"Na'Vi gave me everything when I came into the team. They gave me the kind of family, they asked me to stay"
"But I had some issues, that I couldn't accept and they chose someone else over me so."
GuardiaN’s next team shocked the CS community.
In August 2017 he joined FaZe Clan, and the team acquired Olofmeister shortly thereafter.
They joined rain, karrigan and NiKo to form a multi-national roster that wasn’t hard
to call a superteam.
"Did you ever see yourself playing on the same teamwith Olofmeister on top of with NiKo and now with Rain
on one team?"
"Did you ever imagine that would happen?"
"No to be honest, that's something I would have never imagined."
The consistency shown by this roster far-outstripped the Na`Vi squad he had left.
Though their debut at DreamHack Masters Malmo 2017 was a disappointment, they didn’t let
that get to them.
Instead, they doubled down on hard work: something that GuardiaN was very familiar with.
(Casting)
And the first major with FaZe saw GuardiaN reach yet another grand final.
At Boston, it was GuardiaN dominating in the grand finals series against Cloud9.
(Casting
He was the only player positive on his team in the final.
The action was maybe the greatest of any Major final.
(Casting)
But again, it wasn’t GuardiaN’s Major to win.
The team’s dedication to being the best means that GuardiaN believes that FaZe will
be the last team he plays with before he retires.
"Sooner or later I think it will come, and FaZe Clan will be the last team."
He’s already shown that he is very much in form, and FaZe remains a very real threat.
(Casting)
He will have other chances to win Majors, surely.
But what if he doesn’t?
"Well if I don't win one before I retire from competitive CS, I think it will be very sad."
"Having individual achievements like being the best player in the world is something that is least important
in your career because this is a team game, I don't care if you're the best or not the best, you care about the team
winnings."
Still, whether or not he wins a Major, GuardiaN has been a part of many of the greatest moments
in CS:GO, and created plenty of his own.
From a small competitive region to the biggest stages in Counter-Strike history, GuardiaN’s
path to excellence was forged by sheer perseverance and some of the greatest AWPing the game
has ever seen.
(Casting)
"And he's got all five!"
"There he is, the world's best sniper!"
Thanks for watching. If you want more great content just like this, be sure to hit the subscribe button.